hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the Brookhaven experiment
demo one of the things that you guys
said the last time they recorded a
virtual reality game was that I needed
to be a little bit smoother in my motion
so that you guys didn't get so sick but
the only problem is that when I'm
talking it's a little bit hard to do
everything also you'll notice I don't
have headphones anymore because if you
are wondering yourself why is uncle Mark
EMU screaming at the top of his lungs
like a frickin idiot
well it's cuz I couldn't hear myself and
it's important to hear yourself because
you have no idea how loud you are so I
just ended up screaming very a lot that
is so cool look at this just look at
this are you seeing this I mean what
else would you be looking at but that's
so cool it's a backpack why is that cool
Kabam boom I blew them away my bullets
are disintegration bullets bang oh [ __ ]
ah [ __ ] okay alright then
wave one huh they come in from also I
see you over there BAM did that work
whoa yeah oh that's so cool but he's not
dead that seems to be a problem and I'm
a little tangled here show yourself show
yourself monsters of the darkness
he's not dead this seems to be a problem
oh you're too close okay that guy's
going down okay so I was just missing
what are you doing over there
hah being a sassy
pal nope I'm gonna miss uh I heard okay
you know okay so my main problem is that
I'm a terrible shot and I'm gonna get
devoured to death oh boy
they're coming from all sides this is so
weird I mean considering its virtual
reality in this whole idea but it's just
so disconcerting that these things are
coming towards me like this don't even
think that I can't move around and dance
and get tangled up as such but it don't
matter cuz my skills are unbeatable just
like you oh god this slightly scary now
that's just the demo whoa you were way
too close there buddy wait you glows
alright who else is coming from where
and how oh you don't you uh oh that
ain't good
how do I fix that Oh God take my
flashlight oh don't come near me
oh you son of a [ __ ] ah Beth Beth Beth
Beth how did that work ah you're so
scary ah what if I throw my gun at you
oh he blooded my eyes up well how was I
supposed to do that okay so I'm gonna do
that again but this time I'm gonna let
them get closer to me before I waste all
of my bullets you ran out of ammo try
again well yeah
alright let's do this I didn't even get
past wave 1 so I don't need this until
they get nice and close and so once
again hi how are you doing my name is
Margo Meyer you killed my father
I'm going to kill you now don't even
think about coming any closer I'm gonna
get ya I should have put the wrist
straps on shouldn't I have okay rear
that's yeah that's how we do not until I
see the blood in their pupils
oh I didn't know
AHA now I got you now I am on the top of
the food chain now I am the one with the
NOx okay this is much easier I wonder
also if when I reload I lose the rest of
the bullets in the clip because that is
something that happens in hyperrealism
okay goodbye goodbye goodbye whoa ah
[ __ ]
well I stay there points points got you
ha ha ha I am win or a look at your
grundle actually no one look at your
grundle no one wants to see that okay
okay so far so goo so far so goo okay
I'm gonna see this okay so it does keep
the bullets you don't lose anything from
just reloading and I just have to be
very very snugly put over there there's
somebody over there how about over there
boy I thought I heard something
huh
there we go so long as I aim correctly
down the sights how did how do like like
cops hold it like this don't they but
something like that oh look the sound of
secure I survived ed Oh scavenging ah
yeah I mean it seems like I did a lot
better than that okay yay what does
mutilation mean I don't I don't want
that I'm a nice guy okay great
why'd you throw numbers into my chest
upgrade glow sights I'll take that yes
let's go let's do this whoo awesome come
get him Marga knew Loretta Marga knew is
feeling good I'll see you over there you
think you can hide for me I'm gonna turn
this off cuz I don't need how do I don't
worry there we go all right so you you
anybody else want a party anybody else
want a piece of me a delicious slice of
Marquis mu cake well that's that is
actually a little bit easier whoa you're
big whoa you're big whoa you're big whoa
that guy was big I didn't know there
were gonna be bigger one okay whoa hey
where'd you come from
okay I did not know they're going to
whoa oh okay
never mind then I thought I saw
something oh hello it's big man so they
come charging at me when I shoot you so
I'm not gonna do that I'm gonna wait
patiently for everybody to get over here
a little a little bit lil [ __ ] when I
reload then okay you owe your vibe oh so
scary oh oh okay oh hi sorry I was busy
looking oh he's gone now oh hey buddy
are you doing friend Oh welcome to the
party
hurry there's no one told me this is
gonna be too old whoa what is that oh
what is that oh what is that oh what is
that do any Dame I'm ready
you want some in me I'm right here
ready and waiting whoa boy whoa yee-ha
did I do it did I done zit oh okay thank
you
flashlight batteries that's not really
glow sight batteries wait glow sight how
did I turn on the glow sight laser sight
that sounds better uses custom batteries
but wait I'm just hang on a second this
is but I thought oh so was glow sight
well damn it
laser sight though that sounds good it's
oh look at that ooh
well that's much better I don't know how
to turn that on and off though let's do
it all right now get a laser sight hot
tits that's awesome that's so cool look
at that I mean look at that I said look
at this look at this in my smoothness
I am so smooth I'm so sweet and smooth
ah okay so far so good it's really worth
it it does seem to be taking battery I
don't know how to turn it off to
conserve because I don't want it on all
the time but at the same time oh don't
knock that around I place that just
specific whatever whatever okay
whoo those clothes if I'd have been
reloading when he was coming charging
that would ended very poorly for me see
I'm still kind of worried about the
giant monster that was stampeding
through the city over there
I mean this game is called the
Brookhaven experiment I don't know if
there's experiment that I'm supposed to
be in the middle of this while I'm still
standing in the middle of my campground
in the middle of this abandoned area
where obviously things are going badly
whatever sometimes I just want to take
in the sights I mean that do lose a
sense of self when I'm doing this like I
lose an idea that I'm in my room if like
everything was boiling up around my feet
in terms of the wires and everything I
would be doing this myself
gah anymore does anybody want to come
after me does anybody want something to
do with the marquee Moo what's that I
hear the sound of death I meant to get
that on the first try but it doesn't
matter hello where are you now
oh god damn it I meant to be over there
again now I got it
all right ladies are batteries but but
it's running out right now right now
it's running out but then stupid that's
new beard how do I turn it off okay well
fiddly diddling me I'm just gonna sit
here and in a puddle of pee because I'm
so scared that I'm gonna die all right
come at me bro
but holy crap whoa whoa there buddy whoa
whoa whoa whoa oh you got a vagina face
okay well then okay all right that was
terrifying my god when was that supposed
to be a thing as horrifying
okay so long as another giant guy
doesn't come around I think I'll be okay
whoo take care of him I'm gonna let him
get real close cuz I want to see him I
want them to see me awesome to see me
bang bang bang it's a dead zombie town I
don't even know if he was dead by the
end of that last shot but he's dead now
and I should have I should have worked
this out better so it wouldn't be so
stupid on me wait oh there has a
flashlight oh oh that's handy so when
they get real close I put my gun
literally up underneath them they're
dead just like that you zombie bastards
by the way this game I love this this is
so cool this is exactly what I wanted
out of like a zombie shooter it's just
oh so satisfying they're like right
there they're right there and it's so
scary though oh it's so scary it was
looming he was like right there I mean
my god alright so bigger cliff seems to
be the old
because everything else is temporary I
don't need lasers
I have glow sites or it has sites and I
only really need them to be close and
then I can kill them right away cuz I'm
a freakin badass hello
alright big guy I'm looking for the big
big guys big guy
anybody want a tussle with the muscle
huh anybody Oh
so weird I hear him all around me that's
another good thing about the 3d sound
but damn I'm just looking for big guy
so long as big guys not coming I'm gonna
be perfectly okay no no big guy anybody
everybody here no okay
alright I guess I'm all alone I guess
he's scared - scared of the markimoo huh
you like dancing hello you weren't that
bad that guy's not that big either all
right
want some huh huh you want some huh
whatever what oh what oh sorry
did you want some there Oh what am i a
Mike you awesome for you huh oh what's
that someone over there huh
well that sure was dangerous glad it's
all in the clear meant to hit that on
the first try
boy sure I've known
drop knowing sneaking up behind me Oh to
the right of me
oh did your mind by the way these guys
aren't taller than me / um
they are taller than me but that's not
because I'm short that's just a cheating
the the mutation jeez to turn them into
zombies is obviously making them seem
higher than they really are when in
reality you know bang bang okay
no big guy no big guy no big guy no big
guy oh whoa whoa hey that's a big guy
okay never mind this huh oh boy oh boy
oh boy oh boy
okay I guess oh it was all just a dream
well okay I guess that was the sound of
me being digested in my brain okay uh oh
there we go okay that's it it's so cool
oh that was so cool that was so cool
guys oh that was awesome oh that was
awesome
although so cool oh man you have no idea
that was frickin awesome I got to make
sure that that didn't close out the
recording on me okay so that was the
Brookhaven experiment everything is fine
as obviously you guys saw but everything
is totally fine the recordings fine cuz
obviously you just saw a video there
else it wouldn't be one so thank you
everybody so much for watching I'm
refining the setup as I go but I need a
lot of advice because I can't really do
a whole lot with my room but if I can
make it a little better for you guys
watching I will do my best so thank you
everybody so much for watching check out
other cool games that I played in
virtual reality in the description below
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye
good fatty
that's not even